One of the criticisms that some people
have of online education is they
suggest that the kind of collaboration
we can have in person is
difficult to do online.
If you're taking an online class, the
teacher can say, hey, get into groups
and discuss this topic or complete this
activity, and you move your desks around
and you move around in a lecture hall,
you sit face-to-face with one another,
you do something, and then you break and
go back to the regular class.
And some people point out that
it's difficult to do that online.
And even more so,
things like group projects that are very
valuable in traditional education
can also be difficult to do
when you can't meet in person.
You can't gather around a table and chat
about ideas or scribble on paper and
share it with one another.
So how can we develop technology that
let's people actually collaborate on
projects or learning at a distance?
There's a field that tries to address
this called computer-supported
collaborative work.
It tries to develop tools that
allow people to collaborate,
even when they're not
colocated in the same room.
But it's actually not just
about online learning either.
It's not just focused on developing
tools that allow people to collaborate
when they're not colocated.
It also tries to develop tools that
make collaboration easier in general.
A very simple example that can
be considered something of
an instance of computer-supported
collaborative work is Google Docs.
That's a document interface that let's
multiple people edit the same document
at the same time.
If you've done anything before
Google Docs came along,
you probably remember the days when you
had to pass the document around amongst
people and tell who was doing the edits
at a given time and control for
versions and
do a lot of headachy things like that.
But with Google Docs, we can all log in
to the same document at the same time,
collaborate on it, and move on.
So computer-supported collaborative work
is not just about learning together,
not just about collaborating
on learning activities.
It's also about collaborating
via computers in general.
But in this class, we're going to really
talk about how we can use technology to
enable collaboration in
the context of education.